OUR REGULARLY SCHEDULED VISIT
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE HEARING-
AND WE NOTICED THE PRESENCE OF
MEMBERS ON BOTH SIDES THE I
ALSO WOULD BEGIN IN FOR A
FOLLOW ORDER NOTICE ABSENCE OF
A QUORUM SO WE'LL GET TO THAT I
WANT TO STOP IS COMMON IN THE
MEANTIME THEN WILL BE ACTING AS
A SUB COMMITTEE WE BEGIN THEN
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH
IS AB ONE FIFTY SIX. BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL. PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY AND AGAIN WE'RE
ACTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
WELCOME. CHAIR MEMBERS. TODAY I
PRESENT TO YOU A. B. ONE FIFTY
SIX I WANT TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME IN MY OFFICE I
HUMBLY HUMBLY AS FOR YOUR
IPHONE. WELL SAID ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AT I'M SORRY IN THE-
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. AT CNN ANY
WITNESSES A MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE AND
WILL PROVIDE YOU UP TO AT TWO
MINUTES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
AGAIN WE'RE NOW AT. OPPOSITION.
JOHN. THANK YOU. WELCOME GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS ALLISON
FLEMING I'M VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR ONE
EIGHT HUNDRED CONTACTS THE-
WORLD'S LARGEST ONLINE RETAILER
CONTACT LENSES FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OUR COMPANY HAS BEEN
DEDICATED TO MAKING VEIN CARE
AFFORDABLE. AND ACCESSIBLE
THROUGH INNOVATION. WE'D LIKE
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL.
ARE THE CHAIRMAN AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERING THE
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL. THE
DRAFT AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL
AB ONE FIFTY SIX IN ITS
ORIGINAL. FORM CONTRADICTS
CALIFORNIA'S A LONG HISTORY OF
INNOVATION IN HEALTH CARE AND
SUPPORT OF TELEMEDICINE WHICH
IS GOOD FOR CONSUMERS
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AND
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS. WHEN
THE AMENDMENTS ARE PUTTING
PRINCE TWENTY HUNDRED CONTACTS
WILL WITHDRAW OUR OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CORPS IN JENSEN WITH
TECHNO- WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS AND THINK THE AUTHOR
AND THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF ON ALL THEIR WORK ON
THIS- WHEN THE AMENDMENTS I
REFLECT IN THE ANALYSIS GOING
TO PRINT WE WILL ALSO BE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND IT
NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING I YES PLEASE. MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE ANTIMATTER
HERE ON BEHALF OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ALSO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. SILVIO FOR ABOUT
FOUR BE PARKER LOOK FORWARD TO
GOING NEUTRAL WHEN WE SEE THAT
AMENDMENTS IMPRINT THANK YOU.
MENU LARSON- SPEAKING REGARD ON
BEHALF OF LIEU LACKS STATEWIDE
WORST EASTERN OPPOSITION THE
REDUCES ACCESS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THE NON NON BACK THE
CONVERSATION TO ME MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THIS IS SEEN NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COULD BE MEMBERS
OF MR VOEPEL DO WISH TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EVERYONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN
MR VOEPEL WE WILL TAKE UP THIS
ITEM- WHEN WE HAVE THIS HOUR'S
A QUORUM THIS DOES ENJOY ENJOY
TO PASS RECOMMENDATION THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AS
AMENDED. THEN GO ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER. AND
IN THE MEANTIME AS MISTER
FRAZIER- COMES UP I WANT TO
JUST MAKE A HOUSEKEEPING ITEM
TO A WELCOME THE NEWEST- STAFF
MEMBER FOR THIS IS A PROFESSION
FOR JUST. PATRICK LATE- SO HE'S
ALSO A JOINING US NOW ON THAT
THIS COMMITTEE SO WELCOME
PATRICK. IT'S A FRAZIER PLEASE
GIVE FREE. EVERY READY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. AND
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS. I
APPRECIATE YOU IN YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH MY STAFF AND KEY
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS ISSUE. I
REMAIN DEDICATED TO ENSURE
PUBLIC AND CONSUMER PROTECTION.
IN REGARDS TO ENSURING PROPER
LICENSORS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS TO BE SURE
THAT THIS IS IMPLEMENTED
PROPERLY. AB TWENTY TEN TWENTY
FOUR WILL ESTABLISH A LICENSING
PROCESS FOR HOME INSPECTORS.
FOR MOST PEOPLE A HOME PURCHASE
WILL BE THE BIGGEST INVESTMENT
THEY WILL MAKE IN THEIR
LIFETIME. I BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE NOT ONLY
THE BEST TRAINED WORKFORCE. BUT
ALSO A SYSTEM IN PLACE TO
ENSURE THAT THE CONSUMER. IS
PROTECTED. THIS BILL INTENDS TO
CREATE A LICENSORS THAT WILL DO
JUST THAT. LET ME GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF JUST A FEW
PROFESSIONS THAT REQUIRE A
LICENSE AUTOMOTIVE. BARBERING
TEN COSMETOLOGY. CANNABIS
CEMETERY IN FEWER FUNERAL
CONTRACTORS ELECTRONIC AN
APPLIANCE REPAIR TO SAY IF YOU.
A HOME INSPECTION INCLUDES
EVALUATION OF MAJOR MECHANICAL
FEATURES OF A HOME THAT COULD
PRESENT HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES IF NOT ASSESSED BY IN
INDIVIDUALS WITH PROPER
TRAINING AND EXPERTISE.
ADDITIONALLY THERE CAN BE
COSTLY TROUBLES ARE KNOWN TO
THE BUYER. THAT MAY NOT BE
VISIBLE DURING A SHOWING AN
EXPERT EVALUATION IS NEEDED TO
PREVENT COSTLY AND POTENTIALLY
HAZARDOUS SITUATIONS LATER DOWN
THE ROAD. BY REQUIRING A
LICENSE THIS MEASURE WILL ALSO
CREATE A PATHWAY FOR CONSUMERS
WHO HAVE COMPLAINTS ADDRESSED
BY THAT LICENSING ENTITY IN THE
EVENT THE ISSUES. IF THEY ARISE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I WAS A
CONTRACTOR FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND RECENTLY IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS HAD TO HOME
INSPECTIONS THAT WERE.
GLARINGLY DEFICIENT. AND WHAT
I'M SAYING IS A CONTRACTOR I
WENT THROUGH THE PROPER OF
APPLICATION PROCESS. AND THEN
ALSO HAD A- APPLICATION ALL
RIGHT TEST TO MAKE SURE IT WAS
COMPETENT TO MOVE FORWARD
LUCKILY I PASSED. BUT ON IN
THAT AFFECTS RIGHT NOW TO BE A
HOME INSPECTOR. ALL YOU HAVE TO
DO IS BUY A CLIPBOARD. AND GO
OUT AND DO THESE INSPECTIONS.
UNDERSTANDING THAT. AS I
MENTIONED THE WHOLE VALUE OF
THE HOME THE THINGS THAT COULD
BE MISS THEIR PUT IN THE-
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE UNKNOWING
HOMEOWNER IT CAN COST TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. BUT ALL
I'M SAYING IS WHAT WE WANT TO
DO IS NOT ONLY PROTECT THE
HOMEOWNER BUT ALSO PROTECT THE
INDUSTRY FOR HOME INSPECTORS
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME VERY
GOOD HOME INSPECTORS OUT THERE.
VERY GOOD. THE LICENSING OF
PROCESS FOR THE CONTRACTORS IS
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR THE
APPLICATION AND THEN A TWO
HUNDRED DOLLAR LICENSE FEE. BUT
WHAT THEY GET IS. THAT THEY'RE
VALID TEY'RE ACTUALLY RELEVANT
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO BE PROFESSIONAL. AND WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS JUST MAKE
SURE THAT THE HOMEOWNERS
PROTECTED IN THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE A GOOD INSPECTION
GOING FORWARD FOR THOSE FOLKS
ON THEIR LIFE SAVINGS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WAS FRAZIER AND
WILL PAUSE FOR A MOMENT TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. HELLO DEAR
BRO. ARAMBULA BLOOM. CHEN CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN. FONG GIPSON
GLORIA GRAYSON ALDEN IRWIN
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN OBERNOLTE
TING. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR STEPS A QUORUM AND
WILL PROVIDE UP TO THREE
MNUTES FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PERCENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY YES UGH THE
MORNING- VERY REEFS STEVE CREWS
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION HERE IN
SUPPORT- AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STATED- FOR MANY. THIS IS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT-
THAT THEY'RE MAKING TRANSACTION
AND FEEL IT'S IMPORTANT
INAPPROPRIATE- THAT INSPECTORS
ARE AE PROPERLY TRAINED AND
ABLE TO CARRY OUT THESE DUTIES-
AND IN A WAY THIS COMMENSURATE
WITH THE INVESTMENT SO. FOR
THOSE REASONS WERE HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE NOW LIKE
TO CALL IT MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO
THE- TABLE. AND AGAIN AND WILL
PROVIDE UP TO THREE MINUTES FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. IT'S
COUNTY IDENTIFY YOURSELF AS
WELL. MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DON'T RESPECT A PATH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS HERE IN OPPOSITION AB
TEN TWENTY FOUR. ZERO SPORTS
EFFORTS TO LICENSE AND IMPROVE
PROFESSIONALS WITHIN THE HOME
INSPECTION INDUSTRY. HOWEVER WE
MUST BE MINDFUL OF THE IMPACTS
LICENSING COULD HAVE ON REAL
ESTATE TRANSACTIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS PARTICIPATE IN OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
TRANSACTIONS ANNUALLY. OUR
INTEREST IN MAKING SURE HOME
INSPECTIONS ARE PROPERLY
REGULATED AND LICENSED AS
OBVIOUS. AS A VAST MAJORITY OF
THOSE TRANSACTIONS UTILIZE A
HOME INSPECTOR. THE HOME
INSPECTORS REPORT IS A VITAL
FORMA CONSUMER PROTECTION FOR
BUYERS. SO MUCH SO THAT WE HAVE
A STANDARD FORM THAT REQUIRES
BUYERS TO FORMALLY WAIVE THEIR
RIGHT TO A HOME INSPECTION AND
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT A BUYER IS
ACTING AGAINST THE ADVICE OF
THE BROKER. THEY ARE ALSO DOES
NOT BELIEVE THAT OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING SHOULD BE USED UNDULY
RESTRICT ENTRY INTO A
PROFESSION. THE LICENSING
PROGRAM MUST BE TAILORED TO
BOTH PROTECT CONSUMERS. WHILE
ALLOWING QUALIFIED DILIGENT
HOME INSPECTORS TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE WITHIN THEIR CURRENT
PROFESSION. ASSURING THAT WE
HAVE THE NECESSARY SUPPLY OF
HOME INSPECTORS AVAILABLE TO
COMPLETE INSPECTIONS
NECESSITATED BY THE TRANSFER
REAL PROPERTY. AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS WE HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS WITH THE INITIAL
PROPOSED AUTHORS AMENDMENTS.
WHILE THE AUTHORS MOST RECENT
DRAFT OF AMENDMENTS INCLUDE IN
THE ANALYSIS ARE AN IMPROVEMENT
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY REMAIN UP.
AT THIS TIME. WE ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH ALL ENSURE
PARTIES TO CREATE AN
APPROPRIATE LICENSING PROGRAM
WHICH PROTECTS CONSUMERS. BUT
DOES NOT UNDULY LIMIT THE
AVAILABILITY OF HOME INSPECTORS
TO PLAY A VITAL ROLE WITH IN
REAL ESTATE. TRANSACTION AND
ARTIST YOUR PROCESS. WE FROM
LEAVE THE MORE TIME WE CAN
REACH CONSENSUS ON HOW BEST TO
ESTABLISH A LICENSING PROGRAM
AND ADMISSIONS STANDARDS FOR
HOME INSPECTORS. WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS COMMITTEE.
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU YES MY
NAME IS DAVID PACE I'VE BEEN A
HOME INSPECTOR FOR THE PAST
TWENTY SIX YEARS. PRIOR TO THAT
I SPENT TWELVE YEARS IN
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT AND
SUPERVISION AND BEFORE THAT I
POUNDED NAILS. I'M A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA REAL ESTATE
INSPECTION ASSOCIATION KNOWN AS
CREA I SERVICE THE LEGISLATIVE
CHAIR FOR CREA. CREA IS THE
OLDEST AND LARGEST NONPROFIT
STATE INSPECTOR ASSOCIATION IN
THE COUNTRY. AND THIS
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC IN
EDUCATION AND CONSUMER OUT
REACH. THE VISION OF KOREA IS
TO PROTECT THE LIVES HEALTH AND
INVEST. THE POSITION OF KOREA
HAS ALWAYS BEEN WE ARE NOT
OPPOSED TO LICENSING OF HOME
INSPECTORS HOWEVER WE ARE
OPPOSED TO BAD LICENSING. THE
MOST IMPORTANT STATEMENT OF THE
BILL BEFORE YOU IS SECTION
SEVENTY ONE NINETY FOUR POINT
THREE IT'S STATES QUOTE
PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC SHALL
BE. THE HIGHEST PRIORITY OF THE
AUTHORITY OF HOME INSPECTORS IN
EXERCISING ITS LICENSING
REGULATORY AND DISCIPLINARY
FUNCTIONS. WHENEVER THE
PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC IS
INCONSISTENT WITH OTHER
INTERESTS OUGHT TO BE PROMOTED.
THE PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC
SHALL BE PARAMOUNT. ANY
LICENSING MUST HAVE AS ITS
HIGHEST PRIORITY THE PROTECTION
OF THE PUBLIC. I WOULD NOT WANT
A CONTRACTOR WHO IS NOT FULLY
QUALIFIED TO FRAME MY HOUSE. I
WOULD NOT WANT TO NON QUALIFIED
ELECTRICIAN TO WIRE MY HOUSE. I
WOULD NOT WANT A PLUMBER WHO IS
NOT QUALIFIED RUNNING MY WATER
LINES DRAIN LINES. A CONSUMER
SHOULD HAVE THE HIGHEST
CONFIDENCE THAT HIS HOME
INSPECTOR. EXAMINES TO
STRUCTURE THE ELECTRICAL THE
PLUMBING IS QUALIFIED. HAS THE
EXPERT IT'S TO PROPERLY
EVALUATE LIGHT THE LOCK JUST
PURCHASED THEIR LIFETIME. A
LICENSURE WITH QUALIFICATION
EDUCATION AND TRAINING. THE
IDENTIFIES THE ANSWER IS IN THE
PROTECT THE CONSUMER. BECAUSE
THE PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC AS
THE BILL STATES IS PARAMOUNT
EIGHTY LICENSE YOUR BILL MUST
INCLUDE A PROCTORED CYCLE
INACTIVITY BALLARD
CERTIFICATION EXAM. SPECIFIC
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
NECESSARY TO OBTAIN A LICENSE
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECKS
REASONABLE LICENSING FEES A
REQUIREMENT FOR ERRORS AND
OMISSIONS INSURANCE A SPECIFIED
STANDARD PRACTICE THANK YOU IF
YOU COULD KINDLY JUST WRAP UP.
SURE SO WHILE CREA OPPOSES AS
IT IS AMENDED TODAY AB TEN
TWENTY FOUR WE WILL REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION- IF IT IS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE- CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
THAT I HAVE RAISED AND WE
STAND- READY TO WORK WITH OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND WORKING OUT A-
A LICENSING- BILL THAT PROTECTS
THE CONSUMER AS WELL AS A- AS
THE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF HELP
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
SEE NO ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COULD BE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME AND JUST MISTER
GIBSON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONE
THANK YOU ALL THE FOR BRING
THIS WERE ALWAYS ASSUME THAT
THE INSPECTORS WILL WAS
LICENSED- WHEN THEY CAME TO
SOMEONE'S HOME IS IT YOUR
INTENT TO WANT PROFESSIONAL
LIES- THIS INDUSTRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS CONSUMER
PROTECTION IS THERE BY HAVING
SOMEONE. ASSOCIATIONS LICENSE
TO THIS PARTICULAR PROCESS IS
THAT YOUR INTENT. YES SIR YES I
MEAN YOU KNOW THE TWENTY FIVE
YEARS THAT I SPENT AS A
CONTRACTOR- AND FURTHERING MY
EDUCATION GOING ON TRYING TO
SCORE SEVEN OR SO WHY NOT. WHEN
I HAD. WHAT I WOULD CALL A
LESSON SATISFACTORY EXPERIENCE
WITH. HOME INSPECTOR ON MY OWN
PURCHASE. RIGHT BECAUSE I WAS
AN EXPERT IN MY FIELD I NOTICED
THAT IT WAS. LESS THAN
PROFESSIONAL AND PUT ME AT RISK
SO WE ALWAYS LOOK AS AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TO DO BILLS
THAT HAVE AN IMPACT OR BECAUSE
SOMEBODY HAD A LIFE EXPERIENCE.
THIS IS DEFINITELY SOMETHING
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT. THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE CREDIBILITY.
AND THE PUBLIC- THE PUBLIC OR
THE CONSUMER NEWS THAT THERE
WAS A PROCESS THAT TOOK PLACE.
THAT MADE THEM VALID AND
RELEVANT IN THEIR HOME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND TO THE
SOLICITATION- I HEARD IN YOUR
TESTIMONY THAT YOU WERE
SPEAKING OF. THE FEE THAT WOULD
COST TO. THE INDUSTRY AS REALLY
RELATES TO- THIS PROFESSION-
BEING LICENSE- DO YOU THINK
THAT'S A- MORE GREATER CONCERN
THAN HAVING A PROFESSIONAL
ASSOCIATION BY WHICH THE-
HIGHER FEEL COMFORTABLE KNOWING
THAT SOMEONE IS GOING TO
PROVIDE. AS PERFECT. NEXT YEAR.
AND IT'S NOT THE COST OF IT SO
GREAT OF GIPSON THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION SPECIFICALLY WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT IS AVAILABILITY
OF HOME INSPECTORS AND COST TO
THE CONSUMERS ARE CLIENTS THIS
IS YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE
PURCHASING A HOME USUALLY ON
THE MARGINS- ANY INCREASE TO
THE ABILITY TO PURCHASE A HOME.
LIKE SCHOOL. THE UP. SIDE I'M
OUR CONCERN IS IF YOU RAISE ARE
SO HOT BILL CREE INSPECTION
VIEWED EITHER PEOPLE WAVE
INSPECTION REQUIRE WHICH THEY
SHOULD DO IN ORDER TO HAVE A
THIRD PARTY COME IN- AND DO
INDEPENDENT. OF. COMPONENT
HOMES CONSTRUCTIONS ARE
GENERALLY LOVE. VISUAL
INSPECTIONS OF THE HOME SIMILAR
TO WHAT REALTORS DO WITHIN THE
TRANSACTION PROCESS- SOMEONE
WILL ALSO REQUIRE IN A BUYER'S
INSPECTION THE HOME INSPECTOR
COMES IN AS AN INDEPENDENT
THIRD PARTY LOOKING AT- THINGS
LIKE OUT LEADS- BIG THEY'RE NOT
EXPERTS IN RUSTON ON EXPERTS
AND FOUNDATIONS CLEARLY- BUT
THEY'RE DOING IT. A GENERAL
VISUAL INSPECTION ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO CLIMB UNDER A
NATION ARE UP IN THE ATTIC- BUT
THEY LOOK AT SORT OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE OBVIOUS WITHIN THE
HOME TO PROVIDE THE DISCLOSURE-
ON AVERAGE WE UNDERSTAND THE
COST RIGHT NOW IS ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER HOME
INSPECTION. THE CONCERN IS IF
YOU GO TO AN EXPERT LICENSE
WHERE YOU HAD SAY CONTRACTORS
DOING IT. THAT'S A SPECIAL
DISCLOSURE- HOME INSPECTORS OF
TOLD US THAT WOULD RAISE THE
COST OF THE INSPECTION TO BE
AROUND TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AS WE'VE HEARD ANECDOTAL AND
WE'VE- TO GET THE WILL OF THE
BOTTLE TEN YEARS. SO WE'RE NOT
POST. THING PRO. JUST BE.
CAREFUL WE DON'T. INTEND
CONSEQUENCES. OF WITHIN THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS THE-
REQUIREMENT IS THAT FIVE
HUNDRED INSPECTIONS BE
CONDUCTED OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS. THAT'S TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY INSPECTIONS ANNUALLY. IN
ORDER TO BE GRANDFATHERED INTO
THE LICENSE- THERE'S ONLY THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS IN A
YEAR AND I'M NOT SURE THAT TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY IS AN
ACHIEVABLE STANDARD. FOR THOSE
THAT. ARE PROBABLY STILL GOOD
ACTORS AND A LICENSE GRANTED
LIKE EVERYTHING ELSE THERE'S
GOOD ACTORS AND BAD ACTORS AND-
WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE DILIGENT IN CREATING A
WORKABLE PROGRAM WITHOUT THE
INTERNET CONSEQUENCES. AND I
THINK THE INTENT OF THE AUTHORS
OF MAKING SURE. THE WEEDS OUT
THE BAD ACTORS IN THIS PROCESS
BY CREATING A LICENSE- AND SOME
BENCHMARKS IN ORDERS FOR. AN
INDIVIDUAL OR COMPANY TO HAVE
SUCH A LICENSE. PLATE THAT
WOULD WANT PROTECT THE CONSUMER
WAS PURCHASING THAT. THE HOUSE
BECAUSE THAT'S WE WANT TO DO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE. THAT
INSPECTION IS SUCH. BY WHICH-
THE PERSON'S. PURCHASING A
HOUSE THE HOUSE IS. IT'S A
PARTICULAR STANDARD. AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT THE INTENT IS
AN HOUR. ARE YOU. I WORK BROUGH
I MEAN AND SIR DID YOU GUYS
HAPPEN HOPEFULLY YOU GUYS WILL.
BE A SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL- I
AGAIN I ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT THE
INSPECTOR WASN'T BACK LICENSE
COMING INTO. MY HOME BECAUSE WE
PURCHASE A HOME THAT'S OF YES
NO THAT'S NOT A SMALL SITUATION
THAT'S A HUGE INVESTMENT AS WE
WILL MAKE SURE THAT THE-
INDIVIDUAL PURCHASING THE HOME.
IS COVERED AND SO ONE THANK GOD
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE SAME.
THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING- AND SO
IS IVORY THE BILL ALSO READ
THAT THERE'S A DELAYED AND
IMPLEMENT IMPLEMENTATION TO
GIVE PEOPLE TIME FIVE YEARS
FIVE YEARS CORRECT- AND AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD AND I THINK
IT SOUNDS LIKE WITH OPPOSITION
AND YOU WERE ALL TRYING TO GET
TO THE SAME PLACE. JUST TO MAKE-SURE THAT THERE'S A GOOD
PROCESS IN PLACE. PEOPLE BUY
HOMES AND THAT THEY'RE SAFE AND
SO I'M SURE YOU'RE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS AS AS IT MOVES
FORWARD IN. THE FIVE YEAR
LIMITATION OR THE HOURS ALL OF
THAT THAT SOUNDS LIKE THOSE ARE
DETAILS THAT CAN BE WORKED OUT.
AND THAT WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
HEAD TO THE SAME PLACE AT. THAT
IS FAIR AND ALSO. BOTH OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
ASSOCIATIONS HAVE BEEN WITH US
FROM DAYONE AND SO- NOT THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GO AND BE AN
ADVERSARY WE'RE ACTUALLY TRYING
TO GET TO YES AND- MATTER OF
FACT I THINK THE GENTLEMAN.
GROW TO BE IN IT ORIGINAL BILL
FOR THIS AND WE HAD TO AMEND
BECAUSE THERE WAS CERTAIN
THINGS WERE PROPRIETARY THAT WE
DIDN'T AGREE WITH THAT WE THINK
THEY SHOULD BE NOT JUST THEIR
ASSOCIATION BUT ALL INCLUSIVE
THE CALIFORNIA HOME INSPECTORS
AND SO WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA
WORK TOGETHER AND AGAIN WE CAN
AGREE TO DISAGREE ON SOME
THINGS AND WAS WE MAY JUSTHAVE
TO AFFORD. BUT UNDERSTANDING
THAT RIGHT NOW- YOU BY
CLIPBOARD YOUR HOME INSPECTOR.
IT'S A GREAT CITY. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND I THINK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IN THIS
VERY IMPORTANT BILL THAT I DO
SUPPORT- TO THE ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS DO YOU HAVE. A MATRIX
OR SOMETHING THAT YOU MEASURE
TO OR LOOK AT AS GUIDELINES TO
QUALIFY A HOME INSPECTOR. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
QUALIFIED TO DO THAT WELL. SO
REALTORS ARE NOT SORT OF A
WATCHDOG IT'S NOT OUR POSITION
TO BE ABLE TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT- THEIR LICENSE OR NOT
I'M ARE REALTORS GENERALLY WILL
PROVIDE A LIST OF HOME
INSPECTORS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
SOME THEY'VE WORKED WITH BEFORE
SOME THEY HAVEN'T BECOMES A
LIABILITY STANDARD IF THEY
RECOMMEND ONLY ONE- AND SO WE
GIVE WE GIVE A LIST OF
INDIVIDUALS AND THEN- CAUTION
THE BUYERS THAT. THEY NEED TO
INTERVIEW THE HOME INSPECTORS
THEMSELVES TO DETERMINE WHICH
HOME INSPECTORS GOING TO BEST
FIT THEIR NEEDS RIGHT BUT YOU
DON'T HAVE A- A SET OF
GUIDELINES OUR METRICS TO
DETERMINE WHETHER A HOME
INSPECTORS QUALIFIED OR NOT TO
ACTUALLY DO HOME INSPECTIONS.
NO IN FACT NOBODY REALLY KNOWS
WHAT THE UNIVERSE OF HOME
INSPECTORS ARE STATEWIDE WHICH
IS PART OF WHAT THE PROBLEM IS
AND WHAT WE'VE HAD DIFFICULTY
GRAPPLING WITH WITH AMENDMENTS
WITH THE AT THE MOMENT IN ORDER
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT KIND OF
IMPACT THE LICENSING PROGRAM
WOULD HAVE- WE KNOW IN ORDER
THERE'S- TWO FIVE ARE LIES
THESE UP- BUT- OBVIOUSLY THAT.
LARGER WE KNOW OF CREEK IS
MEMBERSHIP I THINK IT'S
SOMEWHERE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
OF FIVE HUNDRED HOME INSPECTORS
THEY'RE KIND OF THE GOLD
STANDARD THAT'S OUT THERE- BUT
QUITE FRANKLY WE ALSO HAVE AYE
SHE IS IN THE HOME INSPECTOR A
TRADE ASSOCIATION I'M OUR
CONCERN IS MAKING. INDIVIDUAL
HAVE OCCUPATIONS CURRENTLY IN
BEFORE YEAH RIGHT CONTINUE TO
PROTEST ABOUT OCCUPATION THEY
HAVE TO SPENDING AN FOR TEN
YEARS WHETHER THEY HAVE
MEMBERSHIP IN A TRADE
ASSOCIATION OR NOT. OKAY SO IT
SOUNDS. IT IS A- AS WE- TYPE OF
PROGRAM I WOULD AGREE CAUGHT.
WITH WITH FIVE YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION I GIVES US
PLENTY OF TIME TO ADD ANY
WRINKLES AND MOVE FORWARD SO I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MR WHAT HAD. I THINK YOU'VE
HEARD THE COMMENTS- FROM MY-
COLLEAGUES I. IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THIS VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC THAT- THE OPPOSITION
DEFINITELY BRINGS UP SOME GOOD
POINTS SO I WOULD HOPE THAT- IF
YOU PASS THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE
THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK.
SO. IN ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE MISTER
FISHER JEWISH TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. RIGHT NOW IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS NOT REQUIRED
TO HAVE BY LAW THE HOME
INSPECTION. AND THE AND THAT'S
YOU KNOW KIND OF A SCARY THING
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT A LIFETIME
INVESTMENT- BUT WHEN YOU HAVE
PEOPLE COMING IN YOUR HOME. AT.
HAVE NO RELEVANT KNOWLEDGE OF
THAT DWELLING OR HOW IT WORKS-
THAT'S SCARY ALSO. AND SO YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'M
I'M I'M WANT TO THE COMMITTEE
TO KNOW HIS FROM DAY ONE WE
CALLED IN THESE TWO INDIVIDUALS
TO WORK WITH US. GOING FORWARD
WE HAVEN'T TRIED TO PUSH
ANYTHING WITHOUT. EATING TOO
YES ON THIS ON THIS- ON THIS-
ISSUE- FIVE YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION- ALSO
UNDERSTANDING THAT AND I HEARD.
A COMMENT ABOUT A TWELVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR INSPECTION. IF
THE LICENSE FEE IS TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS. FOR TWO YEARS. I DON'T
KNOW HOW THAT WOULD INCREASE
YOU IF YOU HAD TO HUNDRED
INSPECTIONS TO AMORTIZE OVER A
HUNDRED TO TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
A YEAR HOW WOULD RAISE IT TO
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS BUT ALSO
INDIVIDUALS HAVE THE ABILITY
NOT ONLY TO CALL HOME INSPECTOR
BUT THEY CAN CALL A LICENSED
GENERAL CONTRACTORS THEY WANT.
AND WE CAN MOVE TO THAT
DIRECTION. IF THAT'S THE WILL
OF. OF THE PEOPLE I MEAN
SERIOUSLY THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT BUT THERE ARE YOU LICENSED
THEY'RE KNOWLEDGEABLE THEY'VE
BEEN TESTED. AND WE CAN WE CAN
MOVE THAT MOVE THAT BALL THAT
WAY. THAT WILL DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE THE COST OF A HOME
INSPECTION. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ESCRIBO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER FRAZIER- WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR WORKING- WITH OUR
OFFICE AND WITH COMMITTEE STAFF
AS WELL- CREATING A NEW LIKE
THIS CATEGORY IS QUITE
SIGNIFICANT A MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO YOU SHOULD ALSO
KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR AT
PROPOSED THIS LAST YEAR- BUT
YEAH- SUBSEQUENTLY DID NOT AND
NOT HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SUBMIT A COMPLETE THE SUNRISE
QUESTION- WHICH IS QUITE
EXTENSIVE TO ARTICULATE. WHY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S A
NEW LESSON CATEGORIES- THEY
AUTHOR WHAT. TOOK SOMETIME
DURING THE BREAK A TO DO DUE
DILIGENCE WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
WORK ON THE POLICY OF THIS AND
RICE QUESTIONNAIRE. THAT HAS
BEEN COMPLETED AND THIS IS THE
FIRST POLICY HEARING- AND WE
UNDERSTAND THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT GIVEN YOUR EXPERTISE AND
BACKGROUND. ASSEMBLY IS ENGINE
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS A LIKE
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES.
IT IS CLEAR THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THE LEGISLATIVE AND FOR A NEW
LIFE CATEGORY. FOR CONSUMERS
AND THE RECOURSE THAT CAN BE
PROVIDED A WITH THIS AND I
THINK WE ALL- HAVE SOME ANGST
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT HOME
INSPECTORS AND THE CHALLENGES
THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
TOO SO WE GET. A CLEAR
ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT TO YOU HAVE
DONE YOUR HOMEWORK AND YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO DO YOUR DUE
DILIGENCE NOT ONLY WITHIN THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY BUT ALSO WITH
KEY STAKEHOLDERS IN. IT AS WELL
AND WITH THAT THIS INCLUDES A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. IN A
MOTION AND SECOND COMMITTEE SIX
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
QUESTIONS LAST MINUTE. CHINS HI
SO I PRO BURNOUT. I BLOOM. I'M
AYE CHAN CHAN I CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. EGGMAN
WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN
IRWIN AROUND AYE MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN OBERNOLTE TING TING AYE.
WE HAVE A TWELVE VOTES AND
BELIEVE THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOUR STAFF IS
REALLY AMAZING THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE NOW MOVE ON
THEN TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH
IS ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COURT.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHATEVER READY. WELL THAT'S
YEAH- WELL THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR WONDERFUL COMMITTEE STAFF
SECOND THE NOW WHAT WAS JUST
SAID I'M ACCEPTING THE
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
FIVE OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS-
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT ADDRESSES
TWO KEY ISSUES IN THE
MANUFACTURING PROCESS AND- THIS
IS NOT BEEN ADDRESSED- BEFORE
FOR EDIBLE SO IT'S PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT. THAT THE FIRST PART
OF THIS- THE ABILITY TO CHANGE
A CERTIFICATE OF ANALYSIS UP
FROM A LICENSED- TESTING
LABORATORY. YOU WANT THAT IS
INCORRECT WAS DOODLE ARGUEMENT
ERROR THAT ERROR CANNOT
CURRENTLY BE CORRECTED IN THE
PRODUCT MUST BE DESTROYED- THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW FOR THE
ANALYSIS TO BE UPDATED- SECOND
THE BILL- FOLLOWS CALIFORNIA'S
EXCUSE ME COLORADO'S LEAD. TO
ALLOW FOR TEMPORARY IN MODEST
INCREASES IN VARIANTS ON
CANNABIS AS TEXTING TESTING
TECHNOLOGY IS NOT YET ROBUST
ENOUGH TO SAY THAT IT TO
ACTUALLY ARE CAN- VERIFY THE
INC IS THE INGREDIENTS TO TEN
PERCENT. ARE WITH THEIR FOR
ASKING THAT THIS BE RAISED 212%
FOR ONE YEAR UNTIL THIS
TECHNOLOGY CAN BE- IMPROVED-
THIS IS A MARK THIS IS A MODEST
BILL SEEKS TO IMPROVE
MANUFACTURING SAYS AND THAT.
TOO FROM I SUPPORT WITNESSES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS IS
IN SUPPORT UP TO THREE MINUTES
GOOD MORNING ALICIA PRIEGO ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CAMPUS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMITTEE WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL WE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. AND THE SPONSORS OF AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT AND
BELIEVE THIS MEASURE IS MODEST
IN ITS CHANGES TO THE TESTING
PROCESS AND ULTIMATELY HELP TO
NEW INDUSTRY IN SUPPORT THE
LEGAL MARKET AND CCMA ALSO HAD
ONE OF OUR MEMBER COMPANIES
HERE THE COMPACTION TO SPEAK
FURTHER ON THE NEED FOR THE
BILL AND AS OUR EXPERT WITNESS
AND WE ASK. PRIVATE REALLY.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY THE
MORNING CHAIR I LOW AND- THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME- MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA LOOK PALMER AND THE
CO FOUNDER AT CUBIC INFECTIONS-
KEEP THE CONFECTIONS IS A
CANNABIS AUDIBLES COMPANY WE
HAVE A LICENSE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE OVER TWO
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES ACROSS THE
STATE WERE IN ON FIVE OTHER
STATES AS WELL I'M SIX COULD IN
CALIFORNIA- AND WE HAVE STATE
WIDE DISTRIBUTION- FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT INCREASES THE
VARIANCE OF CVD AND T. H. C.
FROM TEN TO TWELVE PERCENT-
MOST FAILURES RIGHT NOW FOR
CANNABIS PRODUCTS ARE DO YOU
POTENCY- THIS BILL IS WONDERFUL
BECAUSE IT DOES COMPROMISED
PUBLIC SAFETY WHICH IS HUGE-
FARM PHARMACEUTICAL. CAMPUS
PROP IN OTHER ARE USED 15%
SINCE WITH NO PROBLEM I'M IN IT
THIS CAN AFFECT YOUR RESULTS
INCOMPLETE ACTION PRODUCTS MAKE
A PRODUCT DOESN'T PASS IT HAS
TO BE COMPLETELY DESTROYED
INCLUDING THE LABOR AND THE
PACKAGING ON MUST BE DESTROYED
I'M GIVE US PRODUCTS IN
PARTICULAR LOW THC CONTENT AND
SO ON THIS IS AN ACCESS. ARM
SPECIFICALLY IT'S VERY VERY LOW
HOLD. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PROVIDE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TRACY STEVENS
ON BEHALF OF NATURE WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE FOR INDUSTRY
THANK YOU. MY CHAIR MEMBERS
THINK OR FEEL WITH THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COALITION ME FIRST.
ECHO THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS OF
HOW GREAT YOUR STAFF IS WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THIS FEATURE MEMBERS RAND
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF A TO LEAVE-
WE'RE PLEASED TO BE HERE WITH
OUR VERY LATE SUPPORT FOR THIS
VERY IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. CNN ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISH AND SPEAKING
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC SEE THIS SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION WILL GO TO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AND WE
WILL BEGIN WITH VICE CHAIR PRO.
THANK YOU MISTER OF MYST QUIRK
JUST QUICK QUESTION ALL THIS
WAS SET UP IN REGULAR IN
REGULATIONS. WHY DO YOU FEEL
THAT WE NEED A BILL AND PUT
THIS IN STATUTE ONE WHY CAN'T
WE JUST AMEND THE REGULATIONS.
WELL THE FIRST STEP IN GETTING
PEOPLE TO DEMAND REGULATIONS IS
SOMETIMES TO HAVE A BILL TO GET
THEIR ATTENTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ANSWER. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME. KATE BUT A QUICK
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR- SO
THIS IS A BILL PROPOSALS WITH
THE RESPECT THE VARIANCE OF A
10% 212% OF POTENCY OF THC
EXACTLY YES IT DOES THE ALTERED
NOTICE A DIFFERENCE IN THE
DIFFERENCE OF TWO PERCENT. OF
THE POTENCY OF CONSUMPTION.
WELL WE CAN HEAR FROM ONE OF MY
EXPERTS. SO A ON 2% VARIANCE
WOULD BE EXTREMELY MINIMAL SO-
AND IF IN A ON HUNDRED
MILLIGRAMS THC PRODUCT FOR
EXAMPLE YOU WOULD HAVE A
HUNDRED TEN MILLIGRAMS OF THC
VERSES HUNDRED AND TWELVE- AND
NOT TWO MILLIGRAM VARIATION
WOULD- I WOULD I WOULD DIE TEST
CONSUMERS IN A BLIND TEST AND
SAY. ABSOLUTELY THERE ARE NO-
NOTICEABLE EFFECTS OF THAT
AMOUNT OF THE DIFFERENCE- THERE
ALSO HASN'T BEEN ANY TESTING
TO- DETERMINE IF THAT IS A
DANGEROUS AMOUNT OF INCREASED
AMOUNT OF THC SO- NO I DON'T
THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE A
DETECTABLE- NOT FOR ANY. PERSON
WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT DOES. IS THE
COURT TO WHICH CLOSE YES THANK
YOU AGAIN IF- IF THE REGULATORS
ONCE HAVE GOTTEN THEIR
ATTENTION. CHANGE THE
REGULATION I WOULD BE QUITE
HAPPY LAST FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
DOESN'T JOINT YOU PASS
RECOMMENDATION THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PREPARATIONS LOW HI SO I PRO.
WE'RE NOT VOTING ARAMBULA. I
BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CHAN. CHAN I
CHILL. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM NO
EGGMAN EVAN I FONG. PHONE
NUMBER IN GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GLORIA GORE I GRAYSON GRAYSON
AYE HOLDEN. IRWIN AND I MCCARTY
THE AYE MEDINA MULLIN MULLIN
AYE OBERNOLTE TING TING AYE. WE
HAVE A TWELVE VOTES AND LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY.
THANK YOU ARE AGAIN WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH ME AB FOURTEENTHS.
OH OKAY. AB FOURTEEN- SEVENTY
PREVENTS UNNECESSARY WASTE AND
COST WHILE STILL MAINTAINING
TESTING INTEGRITY BY ALLOWING
FOR BATCH TESTING OF
MANUFACTURED CANNABIS AS
OPPOSED TO TESTING OF SELECTED
RETAIL PACKAGE REPRESENTATIVES.
SAMPLES CANNABIS SOLD TO
CONSUMERS- IS REQUIRED TO BE
TESTED FOR CONTENT AND FOR
COULD KAMAN IT'S BY VARIOUS
TOXICS UNDER CURRENT LAW THESE
TEST MUST TAKE PLACE WHEN
CANNABIS IS IN ITS FILE FINAL
FORM HOWEVER IT IS NOT SPECIFIC
AS TO WHAT IT MEANS FOR
CANNABIS PRODUCT. BEYOND ITS
FINAL FORM CURRENTLY THIS IS
DEFINED AS THE WAY A- CONSUMER
WITH PURCHASED PRODUCT HOWEVER
CONTESTING SHE'S ME CONDUCTING
TESTS ON FULLY SEALED IN
PACKAGE PRODUCTS IS WASTEFUL
AND INTRODUCES UNCERTAINTY
TESTING ENVIRONMENT- AND I WILL
SAY WE HAVE A BIG PROBLEM RIGHT
NOW WITH THE BLACK MARKET. IN
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL. IS TO
MAKE THE BLACK MARKET GO AWAY
BY MAKING IT EASIER CHEAPER FOR
THE GOOD ACTORS THE PEOPLE OF
REGISTERED WHO ARE WHO ACTUALLY
DO TESTING WHO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE- PRODUCTS FREE OF
TOXICS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
WILL STAY IN MARK IN THE
MARKET. AS OPPOSED TO BEING
DRIVEN OUT BY THE CHEAPER BLACK
MARKET IT COSTS A LOT OF MONEY
TO. GIVE A QUALITY PRODUCT AND
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IS
KEEPING SAFETY WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME- REDUCING COSTS- I'D
LIKE TO CALL ON MY WITNESS.
AGAIN CHAIR MEMBERS ALICIA
PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF THAT
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND SPONSORS
OF THE BILL AND ALSO TO BE
BRIEF WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
HELPS SIMPLIFY THE PROCESS
WHILE MAINTAINING TESTING
INTEGRITY AND FURTHER
SUPPORTING AS AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK STATED THE LEGAL
MARKET AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO PROVIDE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO- TO MORE THAN ON BEHALF A
KEY THE CONVICTIONS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN. FRANK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION A
LITTLE LATE ON A SUPPORT TO GET
ON THE ANALYSIS BUT VERY HAPPY
TO BE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS SEEM TO FEEL
A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COALITION
IN SUPPORT THE MEASURE. TRACY
STUDENTS ON THE HAVE A KNITTER
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLICATION SPEAKING
OPPOSITION. SENIOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM CAMINO VERSE.
TINO QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
CAN MEMBERS DOCTOR QUICKLY WAS
TO CLOSE. YES I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON
THIS BILL TO FINE TUNE IT. AND
ADDRESS SOME OF THE TECHNICAL
IMPLEMENT. IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES RAISED BY THIS
COMMITTEE- CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THIS DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION THAT'S BEEN
IN MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
QUESTION IS DO PASS LOW THOUGH
I'D BRO. I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I
BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CHEN CHEN AYE
CHIU. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
EGGMAN. WHEN I FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GLORIA GORE
I GRAYSON GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN
WHEN I MCCARTY. MEDINA MULLIN
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE. TING TING
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY I. FIFTEEN
FIFTEEN VOTES WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OKAY AND THEN I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT DUCT WORK THAT
YOU BE PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
MISTER JONES OR IS THAT CORRECT
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT THAT'S THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE. WELL
AGAIN THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE WORK ON
THIS BILL AND ACCEPT. THE
SUGGESTED COMMITTEE. AMENDMENTS
AB FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE. WILL
INCREASE ACCESS TO BANKING FOR
CANNABIS BUSINESSES. AND
WORKING WITH PEOPLE IN THE
INDUSTRY. THIS IS ONE OF THE
MOST DIFFICULT THINGS I HAVE TO
DEAL WITH- IT WOULD HELP BANKS
BETTER COMPLY WITH FEDERAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
SPECIFIC TO THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. WILL ALSO CODIFY.
PROTECTIONS UNDER STATE LAW FOR
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. AND
ACCOUNTANTS THAT SERVE THE
INDUSTRY. DESPITE THE CONFLICT
BETWEEN FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS
ON CANNABIS. IT IS POSSIBLE FOR
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE
INDUSTRY. HOWEVER ONLY SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN BANKS AND
CREDIT UNIONS IN THE NATION.
OUR CURRENT CURRENTLY BANKING
CANNABIS BUSINESSES. THE
FINANCIAL CRIMES ENFORCEMENT
NETWORK ALSO MANAGE VINCE
FINCEN A REQUIRES THAT BANKS
SERVING THE INDUSTRY FILE
SUSPICIOUS ACTIVITY REPORTS TO
ENSURE THAT THE BUSINESS DOES
NOT VIOLATE ANY STATE LAW OR IS
NOT ENGAGED IN THE AT AND OTHER
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY THESE
REQUIREMENTS ARE BURDENSOME AND
DEMANDING ON STAFF RESOURCES AT
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE WOULD ALLOW
THE STATE LICENSING AUTHORITY.
ARE THE CALIFORNIA. I CAN TRACE
DATA AND OTHER REGULATORY
INFORMATION WITH BUSINESS BANK
AT THE REQUEST OF THE BUSINESS-
THE TRACK AND TRACE SYSTEM
TRACKS ALL CANNABIS PRODUCTS
FROM CULTIVATION TO SAIL- THIS
INFORMATION ALONG WITH OTHER
REGULATORY INFORMATION CAN BE
USED BY FINANCIAL AND
INSTITUTIONS TO VERIFY THAT
EVERY TRANSACTION ASSOCIATED
WITH THE BUSINESS. OUR PRODUCT
IS LEGAL UNDER STATE LAW AND
EASE THE BURDEN IN COMPLYING
WITH VINCE AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ADDITIONALLY
FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE. OR TWO
LEGISLATION PASSED IN ONE IN
STATE WILL CREATE A SAFE HARBOR
UNDER STATE LAW TO PROTECT
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION TO
ACCOUNTANTS THE PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THE INDUSTRY. WITH
ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
SPELL IS OUR CARE MARTIN ST
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF. GREAT THANK YOU
HI GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HI I'M
JUST VERY BRIEFLY CARE MUNSON
ON BEHALF OF SEASIDE COUNTIES
STATEWIDE BUT ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS AUTHORITY A
LOCAL PUBLIC JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY THAT COUNTIES HAVE
DEVELOPED TO COME TOGETHER TO
AGGREGATE AND ANALYZE CANNABIS
DATA. TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
REGULATORY PURPOSES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WE FEEL THAT THIS
BILL PROVIDES AN AND- AN
IMPORTANT TOOL AND THAT WILL
INCENTIVIZE FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS TO WORK THE
INDUSTRY. I TO PROVIDE THEM THE
SERVICES THEY NEED AND HELP
GOVERNMENTS IN THE STATE- I
REALIZE GREATER REALIZATION FOR
THESE PURPOSES WE- URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THINKING. DO YOU. NEED
TO KNOW MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN. ROBERT
WILSON THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT.
MORNING CHECK COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BLAKE JOHNSON HER BATH OF
TEACHERS IF YOUR MAMA HERE
CHOCK SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT CNN
ANY MEMBERS OF PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NO MEMBERS THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEN UNDER TO
QUIRK IT WAS TOO CLOSE. YES
AGAIN WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
MAKE IT IN THE FACT EASIER TO
ENFORCE OUR CURRENT LAWS BY
SHARING INFORMATION- THAT THE
BANKS WOULD LIKE TO HAVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THIS OF IN
MOTION A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EIGHT MOTIONS YOU PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW.
LOW AYE BRO. BRO I ARAMBULA.
REMAIN AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CHEN. CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. EGGMAN. EGGMAN
AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON GIPSON
AYE GLORIA WHERE I GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN IRWIN WHEN I
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MULLIN. WELL I OBERNOLTE TING
NG I. THE BILL HAS FIFTY VOTES
AND LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AREN'T
MISTER- REGGIE JONES SAWYER
SPELL YES I KNOW THAT YOU AND
THE CHAIR ARE A CURRENTLY HELD
IN PUBLIC SAFETY RIGHT NOW. SO
EXACTLY WHERE YOU ARE. THANK
THE GAVEL TO THE VICE CHAIR AS
A PRESENT HE BILLS. THE CHAIR
HAS FILE ITEM THREE AB TWELVE
SIXTY THREE FILE ITEM FIVE AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE AND FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB SIXTEEN SIXTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS RIGHT
YOU'RE AND MEMBERS- THIS THEN
IS IT ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
SIXTY THREE. THERE WAS A MOTION
AND A SECOND. LIKE TO PRESENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS
WITH RESPECT TO CONSUMER
PROTECTION THE AND-
EXPUNGEMENT- OF RECORDS. THIS
IS THE RIGHT BILL SEE THAT'S
THE I'M SORRY THE FOLLOWING MAY
YET SIX THIS IS FILE SEE THREE-
WITH RESPECT TO CONSUMER
MEASURES THAT WOULD- EXPRESSLY
PERMITTED THAT ACTUALLY FROM
FORCING THEIR CUSTOMERS A
SIGNED CONTRACT PROMISING NOT
MAKE COMPLAINTS TO THE CORRECT
CHOI BOARD- SO DID YOU KNOW A
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. HE
WAS CHAIR ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU CAN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT-
THIS IS A BILL THAT HAS- HAD
PROVISIONS IN THE DENTAL BOARD
SUNSET BILL LAST YEAR IN AB
FIFTEEN NINETEEN WE BELIEVE
THAT REALLY- THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL IS TO FURTHER ENHANCE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS- FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THIS IS IN SUPPORT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING ON A BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS SEEING ON. THIS
CHAIR LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOREVER
THERE'S A MOTION A SECOND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB TWELVE
SIXTY THREE MOTIONS TO PASS A
COMMITTEE ON PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION LOW I
THOUGH I BROKE. MY REGULAR
REMAIN AYE BLOOM. THE MAI CHAN
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. EGGMAN. WHEN I
FONG FONG AYE GIPSON. GIPSON
AYE GLORIA WHERE I GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN IRWIN. WHEN
I MCCARTY. THE AYE MEDINA
MULLIN MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE
TING. TING I THAT'S FIFTEEN
ZERO. NEXT ITEM. THANK YOU HAVE
A SURVEYS YOUR THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE. MR
AND THIS IS JUST A FOLLOW UP TO
LESTER SUNSET REVIEW FOR CORE
PARTISANS CLEAN UP AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING A NICER
HERNANDEZ AND WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THE BILL
WHEN I THINK THE- AUTHOR FOR
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR QUITE
AWHILE ON. WITH ALL OF US ON A
GOOD BILL THANK YOU. JIM GROWS
ABOUT THE DEPOSITION REPORTS
ASSOCIATION- ENDORSED MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS THANK YOU.
YVONNE FENNER EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THE COURT REPORTERS BOARD
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR THEIR
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO
CONSUMER PROTECTION WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE IN IN HERE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU TO
SHOW WHAT DECISIONS FOR SEEING
NONE ANY THIS IS AN OPPOSITION
SHE NON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WISHING ASK QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SEEING NONE
RESTRICT CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE THE MOTION IS SECOND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE MOTIONS TO
PASTOR PREPARATIONS LOW. BY LAW
I BRO BRO I REGULAR. RANDALL I
BLOOM. MY CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
EGGMAN. WHEN I FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GLORIA GORE
I GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN
IRWIN. WHEN I MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE MEDINA MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
OBERNOLTE TING TING AYE. THAT'S
FIFTEEN ZERO. OUR FINAL TEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB SIXTEEN SIXTY.
THE MOTION AND SECOND. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND MR VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS THE
EXPANSION BILL- AND TO
ENCOURAGE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO FIND EMPLOYMENT
ACCORDING TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FIVE OF THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE WITNESSES
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WITHIN ASK
THEIR COMMENTS. SAYING IT WAS
CHAIR TOWARD CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE THE MOTION SECOND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SB SIX
INSISTING MOTIONS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS LOW. I KNOW I
PRO. AND LET'S. DO AYE BLOOM
BLOOM AYE CHAN CHAN. CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I EGGMAN AND WHEN I
FONG FONG AYE GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GLORIA GORE I GRAYSON. GRAYSON
AYE HOLDEN IRWIN. AARON I
MCCARTY. THE AYE MEDINA MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE TING TING
AYE. IT'S FIFTEEN ZERO. THEN
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
FILE I'M NUMBER ONE WE DO NOT
YET HAVE A QUORUM- BUT THE BILL
HAS BEEN PRESENTED THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION A SECOND. TWENTY SIX
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB ONE
FIVE SIX MOTIONS DO AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW. LOW AYE
BRO BRO I ARAMBULA RAMBLE I
BLOOM. MY CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GORE I
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN WHEN I MCCARTY. MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MULLIN
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE TING TING
AYE. BUT AS FIFTY TWO ZERO.
OKAY THEN WE'LL GO ABOVE THAT
OF WE HAD ALL THE BILL'S
PRESENTED WITH JUST GO BACK TO
FIVE. AB ONE FIFTY SIX MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHILL. HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE MEDINA OBERNOLTE.
SIXTEEN TWO ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT. AB TEN TWENTY FOUR MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHILL HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY. THE AYE
MEDINA MULLIN MULLIN AYE
OBERNOLTE TING. FIFTEEN TO ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT. AB TOSS SIXTY
THREE MOTIONS YOU PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION CHAU.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE MEDINA
OBERNOLTE. SIXTEEN THIS YEAR
THE BILL IS OUT. AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT MOTIONS TO PASS AS
A MANAGER OF OPERATIONS TO AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE MEDINA
OBERNOLTE. WITH ONE TO ONE.
FOURTEEN THAT ONE THE BILL IS
OUT. AB FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE
MOTIONS YOUR PASTOR
PREPARATIONS CHILL. TO AYE
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE MEDINA
OBERNOLTE. SEVEN TWO ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT. AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY MOTION IS THE PAST YOU
TO AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE MEDINA
OBERNOLTE. SEVEN TWO ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT. AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
FIVE MOTIONS TO PASS AS A
MANAGER OF OPERATIONS TO AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE MEDINA
OBERNOLTE. SEVENTEEN ZERO THE
BILL WITHOUT. ANY SIXTEEN
SIXTEEN MOTIONS YOU PASTOR
PREPARATIONS TO. TO AYE HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE. MEDINA OBERNOLTE.
SEVENTEEN TO HEAR THAT BUT WAS
OUT. I WOULD JUST LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR. THREE MORE
MINUTES FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
TO
. RIGHT. HI. YEAH
. YEAH YEAH
.
THEY DON'T
. WE'RE YOUR